[Music]
[Laughter]
to another exciting episode of Kos and
here I have Skeletor
[Music]
as a talk about the piece that I was
gonna do for this Halloween oh I didn't
know it was how long
and after deciding exactly what I can do
because I thought I had to get a
character whose face is always made up
all the time and his face is boom I grew
up watching he-man cartoons and he is
the villain he is the nemesis so
watching the cartoon I needed the toys
and the toys that I got well you see
they were all right they even came with
a staff and a power sword
[Music]
do me a favor my followers subscribe hit
the notification button if you hit the
notification button so that way I can
find my way back to you you one want me
to come looking for you
would you Oh
so back to the statue from sideshow
Premium Format tons of detail truly
amazing
some would say
it's a crime not to have it
[Music]
I have he-man and his no way I couldn't
have Skeletor so I got him I got him
he's right there
the level of detail autumn is immense
his muscles the color of his skin tone
the texture his hood his face even the
Cape it's a two layer cape on the
outside it's rough and nasty but on the
inside it's soft and silky he even has
his Power Sword on his back it's amazing
[Music]
hey hey listen
not gonna take too long on this cuz I
really want y'all to go and enjoy your
day make sure you check all the candies
for the children you know we don't want
any mishaps also also be safe and
cautious Halloween like follow subscribe
right I said that right yeah I think I
did I think I did and make sure you go
to Lords of gaming dotnet you can get
other episodes of careless and and and
you can find the last word
a little cut needle Lord addict does
hard gaming reviews we have a ton of
writers who are writing their hearts out
for you
you wouldn't want those hearts to go to
waste right I mean somebody has to pick
up all the blood hey stick around so you
can see the statue
in all it scores
[Music]
I think that
you can have to go back and take a
couple of more meds but I won't do it I
won't do it until after after I complete
my task see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]